[Music]
Paul can't come soon enough because
that's when a very Brady renovation
premieres on HGTV now et has been there
for every single step of this journey
and we were just with the cast
who's gearing up for a big Brady
takeover
when I walked through that front door I
had goosebumps and shivers all over and
I truly felt and saw Florence and Bob
sitting on on the two chairs opposite
the the coffee table in the dining room
and I saw Annie coming in from the
kitchen with a big pot it was
overwhelming it took two hundred three
days six Brady's and two property
brothers to turn this into fists it
looks exactly like a Brady Bunch episode
because it's porkchop's
Clarke Josh I needed to be part of the
kitchen and so even I were paired up in
the kitchen and the family room and
while we all know the iconic 70 sitcom
was shot on a Hollywood sound stage the
Studio City home that was used for the
exteriors was a mystery to the cast we
didn't even know where it was I didn't
know where it was it too like 96 they
have now taken and made it the set we
worked on as well only we were with the
Brady kids when they got their first
look at the finished product now HGTV
will finally reveal the groovy digs to
the rest of the world in the new
four-part series a very Brady renovation
it was crowdsourcing there's meters
people all across the country that
bought something because they saw it on
the Brady Bunch
no get some little knick-knack and they
liked it because of that and these
people a lot of them have volunteered
these items and a Brady fan out of
Minnesota had the same refrigerator from
50 years ago and they donated it
seriously I don't want to let it go it's
just so they can't I'm so attached to
this house and the people and the
memories and everything a very Brady
renovation premiere September night on
[Music]